hallo ihr apfelkuchen verrückten warum
das weiß warum kein bisschen apfelkuchen
verrückten weil immer wenn ein
apfelkuchen rezept kommt dann raste
komplett aus und die rezepte die
erhaltene einzug in die persönlichen
rezeptbücher und bei diesem rezept ist
es bestimmt auch so ich zeige sie
zuallererst mal die zutaten für den
boden und für die streusel denn es wird
ein schöner apfel streuselkuchen mit
magerquark füllung
wir benötigen mehl zucker habe ich weiß
und braun und außerdem weiche butter
jetzt krempeln wir die ärmel hoch denn
ich bin uns heute keine große
küchenmaschine nur gleichen hand röhre
aber den hat er jeder zu hause und sage
ich jetzt die zulage die ich euch gerade
genannt habe einfach in eine größere
schüssel und vertrete das zu einem teig
[Musik]
also mein tag ist jetzt fertig geknetet
und zwar ist das jetzt und ike der dient
ja später auch unseren streuseln und
deswegen ist es eher krümelig aber wenn
ihr richtig zusammen durch dann bleibt
es oft fest und ich nehme jetzt die
hälfte bzw ein bisschen mehr als die
hälfte davon und gibt es in meine mit
backpapier ausgelegte springform ich
habe hier 26 zentimeter im durchmesser
aber es würde zum beispiel auf 24
zentimeter gehen so der boden ist schon
angedrückt ich zeige euch das mal das
gebe ich jetzt aber ganz kurz an die
seite und hier habe ich meine straße die
brauchen wir auch gleich ist wieder und
ich zeige euch jetzt die abfüllung und
zwar benötigen wir erfüllt magerquark
hier habe ich butter geschmolzen etwas
abkühlen lassen
zucker speisestärke eier und vanille
extrakt oder vanille zucker für die
füllung nehme ich jetzt alle zutaten bis
auf die äpfel und gibt es in eine
ausreichend große schüssel und verrührt
das miteinander
[Musik]
so das umrühren hat jetzt ungelogen 30
sekunden gedauert das war's auch schon
jetzt kümmern wir uns aber um die äpfel
gibt die creme zur seite und die äpfel
die werde ich jetzt ganz einfach stehen
dann könnt ihr einfach schauen ob jetzt
schreiben nimmt oder quadrate würfe
genau würfel ist es so das wort was mir
jetzt fehlte ich mache ganz spontan
schauen
ich habe mich jetzt für würfel
entschieden und ich gebe jetzt meine
apfel würfel zurück in die creme dürfen
sie ja in die creme dann ruhig das ganz
kurz um
[Musik]
also die apfel quark bildung geben wir
jetzt auf unseren boden und danach
kommen die streusel obendrauf und den
oft habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt auf
200 grad ober und unterhitze und dann
packen wir ihm ca 50 minuten aber ich
bin halt irgendwie ein bisschen schnell
wieder merke ich immer piano also genau
wie fällt erstmal einen streichen platz
[Musik]
also es ist noch ein bisschen offen wie
man dann keine sorge ich halte jetzt mal
gang runter aber ihr seht das rezept ist
einfach super schnell und deswegen
quatsche ich hatte auch so schnell also
ich gebe jetzt die streusel obendrauf
und dadurch dass wir den braunen zucker
drin haben wird das später richtig schön
knusprig
dankeschön der strom kommt jetzt in den
ofen nie gesagt circa 50 minuten bei 200
grad ist kann auch sein dass der 60
minuten dauert kommt halt immer auf den
ofen an und ich würde sagen haben sie
damals ist das geschirr und ich kümmere
mich ums mittagessen
danke auf jeden fall so mein apfelkuchen
ist fertig superlecker einfach ohne
alles was ihr braucht nichts mehr machen
ich gebe da höchstens allerhöchstens nur
noch puderzucker obendrauf für die optik
und das war es dann auch wenn ihr das
ganze jetzt nachmachen möchte schaut
hier unten in die infobox rein
das schreibe ich euch wie immer die
genauen mengenangaben und ich möchte
unbedingt fotos sehen von dem kuchen mit
dem hashtag liches kitchen auf instagram
und facebook falls ihr weitere rezept
wünsche habt immer gerne unten in die
kommentare ein schreibt ansonsten
abonniert main kanal wenn es sie schon
längst getan hat aber ich bin sicher ihr
habt schon längst getan und dann sehen
wir uns auch beim nächsten mal wieder
auf die skating skis
[Musik]